I'm ranking the top 100 Secrets most
people don't know about one piece and if
you want to see if you're a true one
piece expert keep watching all the way
to number one to see just how many of
these you actually already know starting
off with our first mind-blowing fact
which is that the anime completely
skipped The crucial first chapter of the
manga until episode 4 leaving first time
viewers unaware of Luffy's entire
backstory which might sound crazy but
that's just the beginning because Nami
not Luffy was the very first Straw Hat
to actually appear in the anime looking
fabulous while Undercover on a random
passenger ship here however there is
absolutely no way that she would have
been able to sneak around undercover if
Oda had actually stuck with nami's
original design that's because in her
very first design she had both a
mechanical arm and foot plus she had
this totally badass battle ax kind of
wish she would have kept that and also
really curious how that would have
changed her journey throughout the story
though I bet you never realized that
Nami and Robin are the only crew members
to ever betray Luffy that's because Nami
stole their ship and Robin framed the
crew for assassination seriously don't
mess with any of these women now what's
even more incredible is that many of
these most famous pirates in one piece
have actual real world Inspirations you
might for example know that Blackbeard
and Whitebeard were clearly inspired by
the real Edward Teach also known as
Blackbeard but Roger's famous execution
scene was actually inspired by a French
pirate who gave a famous puzzle during
his execution among many others the
silky smooth alvida has a real-life
counterpart as well as does Julia Bonnie
and even Roxy's back was inspired by a
Brazilian pirate right here and going
from some of the most important pirates
in the story let's now discuss some of
the most Secrets like this funny guy
here which is pandemon a character that
Oda often draws in the background of
chapters and while pandemon may appear
as a simple gag character he possesses a
full backstory complete lead with a
lover a rival and a whole gang to whom
he owes a lot of money apparently
however Panama is not the only
reoccurring secret character because
this is mantomo the traveling Carpenter
who specializes in fixing broken things
now one of his notable repairs involved
the door to this bar which had been
broken all the way back in chapter one
and we can forget about Sam which is
this ball drunkard who sometimes shows
up having a few too many drinks in the
story which now brings us to actually a
completely different type of secret
because amazingly both Sanji and Brooke
actually had a strikingly similar
introduction to the story both were
wearing a black suit and both were
holding hot liquids that was soup for
Sanji and coffee for Brooke plus both of
them are the most perverted members of
The crucial of Super Series what other
similarities we might learn about them
in the future however that's of course
not the only insane hidden fact about
Brooke because he's officially the only
straw hat ever to never meet either of
Luffy's Brothers Sabo or Ace which might
seem a little bit weird but did you know
that among all the characters in one
piece this massive man or Rouge embodies
the essence of a true pirate with his
Hobbies which include traveling drinking
and well um lovemaking but who would
want to have let's just not go there I
don't even want to think about it
because while a Rouge may be getting
plenty on the side apparently the same
really can't be said for kid and killer
and that's because they once shared a
childhood Crush but when both of them
laughed at her for spilling Curry she
promptly beat both of them up so so much
for punk rock and love however the same
can be said for Blackbeard because these
two ladies here we see hanging off him
are actually called Tori and Maki which
if you put them together are horimaki
and in Japanese this roughly translates
to Gold Digger in other words a woman
who sleeps with men for their money so I
guess good on Blackbeard question mark
on the other hand one pirate who's
definitely not getting any of the ladies
is the cat loving fake Butler right here
and that's because Oda has officially
confirmed that these weird little golden
blobs on his jacket are actually meant
to be poop which was kind of gross
however make fun of him at your own risk
because he backs a serious punch in fact
you might not know that the former
Marine Captain Morgan once actually
tried to capture Kudo but the cat pirate
broke his jaw which is exactly why
Morgan has this metal mouthpiece instead
and as unlikely as it may sound Kuro is
actually not even the weirdest member of
his own crew because that honor
definitely belongs to Django who has the
weird stem looking facial hair here but
it does turn out that this is not even
hair instead Oda has confirmed that this
is actually the stem of a mushroom that
somehow started growing on Django's face
which maybe he should just be taking a
shower for that I don't know however
amazingly what is not fake is this Godly
luxurious facial hair however what you
might not know about Goldie Rogers
famous mustache is that Oda originally
plan for this to just be super long nose
hairs like yikes kind of gross again and
while Ace didn't inherit his father's
impressive facial hair he is actually
the only known character in the entire
story to reject an invitation to join
the world government's Warlords props to
Ace now have you ever wanted to have
Luffy's courage or magically learn his
ability to never get nervous well you
might want to reconsider that after you
hear this because according to the
author of one piece Luffy is only like
this because he is a complete idiot who
doesn't know any better but okay okay
even if you knew that fact did you know
that we almost had this in the story
that's right Sanji was originally
planned to be called Naruto but since
the Naruto that we all know and love was
becoming its own popular manga series at
the same time Ichiro Oda the author of
One Piece decided to change his name to
avoid unnecessary confusion which
alright brings us already to 20 facts so
did you know all of these so far well
even if you did it I bet you didn't know
that the pirate Empress Boa Hancock
actually appeared on the cover of Shonen
jump all the way back in 1999. in other
words that is nine whole years before
her actual introduction in the story you
also might not know that she's not even
the only character to appear in a
magazine that's because in chapter 762
loss Mentor Corazon is reading a
newspaper that shows the warlord
crocodile now apparently this specific
article was praising crocodiles heroism
for hunting down Pirates during the
early years as a warlord which is pretty
interesting and while the incredible
recent events of cross Guild have
crocodile teaming up with the world's
strongest Swordsmen here is a little
known fact about mihawk that's because
apparently he was famous even before
Roger's execution began the great pirate
era which does make me super curious
what exactly he was doing during all
that time and as we discussed in a
recent chapter review it's actually
possible that he might have been working
for the world governments however this
next fact goes back even further before
the celestial dragons even existed in
the first place and that's because the
earliest event that we have an official
date for in the story is the Golden Age
of shandora which was stated to occur in
the year 402 which is about 1 100 years
before the current story although we do
know that probably Alabaster is even
older than that however this next fact
is just as incredibly old and that's
because the animal Ming tribe has been
confirmed to be living on the back of
this giant elephant for 1 000 years
which means that they were outcasts even
before the void Century though would you
believe me if I told you that there is
an even more secret and mysterious
elephant than zenisha well listen to
this because the new ward of imple down
has a strange obsession with underwear
in fact Oda shows us his collection in a
questions Corner including this one
called Mr elephant
um where do they sell those exact
exactly anyways back to the video What's
even crazier though is that apparently
Shanks has been putting his uh own
elephant to work as well if you know
what I mean because in the cover of
chapter 614 we see the bartender of
Luffy's Hometown Makino holding this
young child and when asked who the
father of this child was Oda simply
replied that it is probably Batman which
come on strongly suggest that it is
Shanks since the redhead Captain visits
her bar very often like suspiciously
often as we see in the very first
chapter though what's even more
interesting is that the straw hats
shipped the Thousand Sunny hides a
locked freezer with a passcode in fact
only Sanji Nami and Robin actually know
the combination which is based on their
birthdays just so none of the other
members can access the food and on top
of that the Thousand Sunny also boasts a
surprising library because every straw
had pirate except Luffy has at least one
book in The Collection even Zorro does
enjoy looking at books about swords and
jimbei likely added a bunch of books
about the Seas after joining as well on
the other hand here is probably the most
disgusting fun fact about the ship and
the straw hats because apparently the
men rarely actually use the toilet
instead they just do their business off
the sides which was actually kind of
common for Sailors and many boats had a
crab line on the ship to help Sailors
avoid falling overboard while doing
their business but still might not have
been necessary to share that fact so now
rather than food going out let's talk
about the one man who knows how to
appreciate his comfort food instead and
that's because this guy Virgo finds
comfort in a daily breakfast routine of
hamburgers fries and a strawberry
milkshake which he does look very good
for that sort of diet but one thing he
apparently won't eat is devil fruit
because he is the only one of those
flamingo's officers confirmed to not
have eaten a devil fruit next up though
I have a fact that you'll probably
definitely only know if you are a
die-hard Sanji fan and that's because
over the entire 1000 plus chapters Zorro
has never called Sanji by his proper
name in the original Japanese manga
which is kind of mind-blowing when you
think about it and while many fans do
assume that those two legitimately hate
each other that's actually not true they
actually care about each other quite a
lot in fact they have proven that they
will even risk their lives for each
other such as on Thriller bark or during
one which does mean that this next fact
could have completely ruined the best
Bromance in manga and that's because
this Fierce rivalry almost never existed
in the first place because originally
Zoro was planned to be a simple
bodyguard for buggy meaning that he
would have been left behind a long time
ago which would probably have ruined the
entire series if we're being honest
though at the same time honestly I would
love to see how the story would have
changed if some of oda's crazy ideas
were being included so make sure to
subscribe to the channel if you want to
see a future video on that topic but the
next fact shows us just how sneaky Oda
can be with those that's because he has
actually included his name and the title
of the story itself on various books
throughout the story including in
episode
2170 and even episodes 278 and while you
might be fanatically looking back
through the story at this point do stick
around because you won't believe these
incredible facts about dressrosa that
you definitely missed like did you know
that this Samurai never actually
received a bounty from the doflamingo
family and that's because kanjiro was
actually working for doflamingo's Boss
all along which I guess does make sense
when you look at it from that
perspective and in dress Rosa we also
meet the tontada dwarfs who live on the
island called Green bit but did you ever
realize that the famous explorer Noland
who we already met during Sky Pia
actually found the dwarves during his
travels as well which is why he that
statue there and even if you did know
that I bet you've never realized that
this snow Harpy lady was actually the
very first female character to die in
the entire main story if we're of course
not counting flashbacks and here's
actually another unbelievable fact about
other Logan devil fruit users like that
every of these powerhouses that were
introduced before the time skip were
actually present during the war at
Marine Fort with the sole exception of
the lightning fruit user Eno and what's
even crazy about NL is that he was
actually the very first major antagonist
who was not either a pirate or a Marine
in the story but putting Slim Shady
aside out of all these extremely
powerful devil fruit users at marineford
the very first one introduced into the
story was actually smoker who was also
the very first Marine shown with a devil
fruit all the way back in loketown but
while we wait and pray for another epic
Clash like Marine Fort in the future we
do already know the winner of one of
usopp's most important battles in the
story and that's because usab's nose is
confirmed to be just slightly longer
than this guy's here which let's be real
is the only actual win that usop needs
in the story and speaking of appearances
have you ever noticed that these three
brothers all have incredibly unique hats
I mean come on why doesn't anyone else
in the story have such epic headwear and
while it's hard to believe that Luffy
has the best hat game in the entire
series it's worth noting that Zorro
Sanji and Nami each hold a different
also very important title because they
are the only ones in their 20s in the
entire crew Zara and Sanji are 21 while
Nami adds her youthful charm at 20 and
Luffy is still 19. and although Zoro is
in that honorable Club Zorro also stands
alone as the only member of the first
generation without a devil fruit now to
be fair this guy here also never had a
devil fruit until he was technically
forced to eat an artificial devil fruit
during the wano arc so uh sorry but out
of the club there for you killer and now
shifting gears to a completely different
setting let's delve into some
mind-blowing Revelations about the
prisoners residing in the underwater
prison in pull down and first is that Mr
two somehow magically survived his fight
with the venomous Warden and is now the
new ruler of new Kama Islands but what's
even crazier is that while Mr 2 is still
alive and in prison another former enemy
was one set free and that would be the
Fishman arlong who is the only
individual that we know to have ever
been released from impel down now this
was only allowed because jimbei agreed
to join the Warlords and demanded that
his Fishman brother would be released
which again did not really play out that
well for him and then we have this
insanely strong former prisoner Des
bones who is actually the only confirmed
Bounty Hunter to have ever eaten a devil
fruit however during the chaos of the
impul-down arc Des bones escaped
together with Luffy and went to fight at
at Marine forts but did you know that
the ward Marine Fort included the first
two mythical Zone devil fruits in the
entire story because during this battle
we saw not only Marco's mythical Phoenix
devil fruit but also of course the fleet
Admiral xengoku's mythical Golden Buddha
fruit so uh still feeling great about
your random one piece knowledge or are
you just along for the ride at this
point I mean either way let's jump into
the second half of our hidden fact
secret ranking and to do so we're going
right back to insanely overpowered devil
fruits because at this point we have now
nine mythical Zone fruits in the story
however you might not realize that a
shocking six of them were actually
revealed during the wano art and those
nine are the Yamato no Orochi fruit
kaido's mythical fish fruit this
shape-shifting on yudo fruit Katarina
Devon's nine tail fox fruit Yamato's
wolf deity fruit and of course Luffy's
Nika fruit and that means that the only
other mythical Zone fruit revealed
outside of Marine 4 and wano is the
mythical Pegasus fruit which was
recently shown by the horse stronger
during the Egghead island arc and
although all of these mythical Zone
fruits are absurdly powerful you might
not have realized that basically none of
them are as strong as akinu's magma
fruit in fact did you know that the
kindness powers are so strong that he
was able to destroy one of aokiji's legs
and leave him with Burns along all of
his arm in fact Oda once stated in an
SBS that if a kainu were to be the main
character of the story he would have
finished one piece in less than a year
but now let's shift our Focus to another
mind-blowing example of foreshadowing
because did you know that in the anime
zoroge fluffy a striking ex-car on his
chest that was incredibly similar to the
scar that he received from this magma
fist later on in the story I mean talk
about some incredible foreshadowing even
if it was a filler episode and speaking
of some very good foreshadowing did you
realize that when Sanji gave himself the
a nickname Mr prince in little garden it
was actually foreshadowing for sanji's
True lineage being a prince of the VIN
smoke family and while it did take over
600 chapters for that foreshadowing to
pay off jimbe is also another example of
oda's incredible long-term planning and
that's because he was directly mentioned
way back all the way in chapter 69 but
was not officially revealed in the manga
until a staggering 459 chapters later on
the other hand Robin burst in without
any invitation at all in fact she is the
only straw I had till this day who Luffy
never invited to join the crew in the
first place but beside that do you know
who are the hardest characters to draw
well that would be the most beautiful
woman in the world Boa Hancock and also
the mermaid princess shirohoshi
I do wonder why but sticking with our
favorite mangaka Oda once shared that if
he could choose a devil fruit power he
would opt in for Robin's Hana hananomi
so that he would be of course able to
use more hands to draw the story now
personally I'd probably choose the
Phoenix fruit but Robin's is very cool
too no question about it now let's get
to some truly Unbelievable Facts about
the world of one piece and its creators
like first did you know that one piece
was only supposed to last for five years
originally
whoopsie I guess and on top of that the
Warlords were never planned to exist in
the story in the first place in fact Oda
had originally only planned for Luffy to
only fight the empress so goodbye to all
of you Chumps but that's not even all of
the major groups of characters who
randomly became a very important part of
the story and that's because Oda
famously made up the entire group of the
Supernova Pirates at the very last
minute before they were then finally
introduced during this
archipelago art which is kind of hard to
believe but did you also know that Nami
is the only Straw Hat to invite someone
else into the crew before Luffy did now
this actually happened back in chapter
140 when she asked Chopper if he wanted
to come along on their grand adventure
and while the chopper we know and love
is of course this adorable little
reindeer Huda almost gave us this
shocking design yeah so this cuddly
looking reindeer was almost a
chain-smoking zebra reindeer hybrid
instead it's actually pretty incredible
just how much some of the crew has
actually changed from their original
designs and similarly did you know that
Chopper's current design was actually
inspired by the most famous reindeer of
them all I mean Chopper just has a blue
nose instead of a red one and his
birthday is even on Christmas Eve and we
all know that Chopper's goal is to save
lives but he isn't the only merciful
member of the crew because surprise
surprisingly Luffy has never actually
killed a major opponent in the series
except maybe kaido but that is still
very much undecided but this is actually
an intentional choice because Oda does
believe that crushing someone's dream is
a fate even worse than dying itself but
of course as you would expect that's by
far not the only hidden secret that
Luffy has up his sleeve in fact we all
know that Luffy wants to become king of
the Pirates but that's actually only one
part of his real dream however we're
still all in the dark about his actual
dream but every time that he has
actually mentioned it to someone in the
story they usually find it quite amusing
and for the next one I do want you to
pause and think for a second about this
because what do you think is the most
disturbing scene in all of One Piece you
have your choice in mind well you're
probably wrong that's because of this
scene during the final battle of the one
piece movie Baron omatsuri and the
secret Island Island and I won't spoil
it for you but it was so awful that it
nearly wiped out the entire crew and if
that's hard to think about just wait
because that's not even the most tragic
fact about one piece a number of the
anime voice actors have actually passed
away during the run of the show and
these include voice actors for jimbei
Rayleigh mihawk singoku smoker Goldie
Roger and a few more and it genuinely
makes me sad that they'll never get to
reach the end of Luffy's Journey
themselves and unsurprisingly Oda is
just as emotionally invested in the
story as you are in fact he often finds
himself moved to Tears by his own scenes
such as bidding a tearful farewell to
the Beloved going Mary or witnessing
vivi's desperate pleas for peace in
Alabaster but now let's actually stick
with Luffy for a little while longer
with some quick hitter hidden facts here
ready alright let's go did you know that
Luffy only baths once a week or that he
is the youngest member of the worst
generation of Pirates and that Luffy has
ranked first in every single one piece
popularity poll plus another completely
bizarre fact is that Luffy usop and
Sanji all three claim to have never been
sick so they don't actually know what it
feels like to have a cult I mean Luffy
has been poisoned at least plenty of
times and he's always survived so maybe
he just has a ridiculous immune system
as for sanjin USA well it's a bit more
debatable if they're telling the truth
or just trying to show off here but
let's rewind all the way to Luffy's
childhood where he'd befriend Sabo in
the class divided Goa Kingdom which is
his home country but the surprise comes
when their paths cross again indres Rosa
which is yet another kingdom plagued by
class divisions with a peculiar twist
it's lower tier citizens are transformed
into literal toys and in addition just
like when Luffy smashed the flamingo
into the ground did you know that there
is one thing that always happens after
Luffy takes down a mage antagonist nope
it's not a banquet but we do always see
Luffy crack that characteristic big grin
within one or two chapters after taking
down a big bad guy so uh that seems to
be his drug of choice I guess but what's
even crazier is that Luffy certainly
deserves those Smiles because he and the
rest of the straw hats have all lost
someone significant to them in their
past whether it be parents mentors
Brothers none of the straw hats are safe
and especially in their backstories and
as strangers that may sound did you know
that the Marines aren't the only branch
of the world government's military
because as we can see in this wanted
poster drawn by Oda there is clearly
Coast Guard written instead of Marines
which is a whole fraction we're just
completely missing out on maybe they're
just too weak but still kind of sad
would have liked to see them so since
the Coast Guard does exist I wonder if
they have a special dish that they eat
every week because apparently the
Marines Friday tradition is to eat a
very special dish called Marine Curry
probably keeps up Morel I guess but even
that is not as surprising to me as
Robin's second job on the straw hat crew
and that's because Robin is also one of
the straw hats hair stylists yep we
learned this in a question Corner when
Oda said that usob and Robin do cut the
crew's hair and then after the time skip
Sanji was added to the hair cutting team
as well wonder why and much to everyone
surprised the world government was
actually more desperate to get their
hands on one particular object than they
actually were about capturing fearsome
Pirates like kaido Shanks or even big
mom and that object is the ope opinomi
and they were willing to pay a
staggering 5 billion berries to recover
it before law then just aided and got
its powers but now shifting from one of
the most valuable things in the story
let's meet the weakest because do you
know who it is well that would be batchy
the small cricket that was unfairly
squished by this Marine during the
baratia arc which now brings us to a few
more in incredible facts about the straw
hats themselves now Oda once confirmed
that Nami was the third smartest
character we had seen in the East blue
only Behind These two however with
nami's growth throughout the story it
wouldn't be surprising if her ranking
has improved since then also here is a
fact straight from the author himself
Usopp will forever hold the title of the
weakest Straw Hat regardless who joins
the crew now this kind of comes from
usab's relatability for normal people
while his crewmates all have
extraordinary powers and yet what very
people actually know is that Usopp
actually does have his own very secret
hidden superpower and that's because
many of usob's lies from the very first
chapter have actually ended up coming
true he did find the Emerald City met a
mole encountered the three-headed dog
fought a dragon and even survived a
giant goldfish but probably no USAF fact
is more important than is his birthday
which is actually on April 1st now this
is hilariously appropriate of course
because April 1st is April Fool's Day in
most parts of the world what is not a
joke on the other hand is the real life
inspiration behind the Revolutionary
Army dragon ship as the wind grandma is
based on a historical yacht that played
a significant role in transporting Rebel
soldiers aiming to overthrow a former
Cuban president does that sound familiar
at all but the most heartwarming fact
about Robin is that before and his Lobby
she did not call any of the straw Hat
crewmates by their name instead she
called them by titles such as Navigator
or cook and this was because she never
actually allowed herself to be fully
accepted as a true member of the crew
until the straw has then actually saved
her from the world governments and just
like Robin even Oda does need to feel
accepted sometimes and one important
milestone for him was passing the number
of chapters in the legendary Original
Dragon Ball Manga this actually occurred
in chapter 519 and to Mark the
achievement Oda included special shading
and toning on the cover page compared to
that one fact that is almost too
shocking to believe is about sanji's
eyebrows and that's because when Sanji
actually used this power raid suit
during his fight in wano his curly
eyebrows literally changed directions to
match those of his brothers and this was
of course hugely symbolic because
sanji's eyebrows have always been
different to show that he's more human
than his emotionless Brothers however
one Sanji rejected the raid suit later
on his eyebrows then turned back to
their normal form which now brings us
into the top 10 most secret crazy and
astonishing facts about one piece and
you probably did not know starting with
that we all know that chapter 1 is also
the moment where Luffy stabs himself
which does result in his very famous
scar but did you ever notice that
Luffy's grandfather and father also have
noticeable marks on the left side of
their faces GARP has this scar here and
dragon has this tattoo so surely this
must have some sort of meaning and I
will give you another hint about its
true importance in the very last fact of
this video but in the meantime while
this is one crazy family it is nowhere
near as insane as the biggest family in
the story and that's because big mom has
been somehow giving birth for 42
straight years she has had 43 husbands
with which she has produced 39 daughters
and 46 Sons ish I mean just uh imagine
what your mom would think if she
imagined 46 of you running around the
house I'm sure if my mom wouldn't be
that happy now what you didn't know
about big mom's strongest son katakuri
is that he's also officially the biggest
donut lover in the entire story in fact
he may hold the record for the most
Donuts consumed in a row of feat that
even GARP attempted to beat by devouring
a staggering
834 of them and he's still lost uh hello
where can I sign up for this donut
eating Championship I mean custard cream
for me please now do you know which of
the most iconic scenes of the story was
almost erased by a real-life natural
disaster well that would be this one
right here that's right we almost never
got to see Blackbeard show off his new
powers in the anime because during this
time a massive earthquake triggered a
tsunami that caused immense damage in
Japan you might remember this that's
because this scene from the anime aired
only weeks before this disaster but I
only have to wonder if they would
probably have taken it out entirely had
the tsunami happened before the scene in
the anime and at number six did you know
that there is one one-piece fan who
absolutely knows how one piece ends and
that's because one young fan who had
lung cancer actually asked to Make A
Wish Foundation if he could learn the
ending of one piece so Oda agreed to
fulfill the kid's last request and
revealed how one piece would end to this
one single fan alone so thank you Oda
Sensei for granting wishes with your
incredible story now what is crazy about
one piece is that sometimes it is super
easy to forget that the actual timeline
of the story is completely different
from the 20 plus years we've had the
story in the real world like can you
believe that the first half of the story
unfolded within a mere four months in
the one piece World itself in other
words Luffy went from this to this in
the same time that it takes to complete
a semester of school like what are all
of us doing with our lives and do you
know that Sabo might actually have been
revealed all the way back in chapter 98
and that's because right here we can see
a character in a black suit and hat who
does look suspiciously like Sabo and he
does show up again right here and it
would make sense that Sabo is here
because dragon again the leader of the
Revolutionary Army of course also has
shown up to save Luffy here and another
shocking fact is that two of the most
god-like and popular characters in the
story have never actually met and if you
don't know I'm talking about the God of
Lies Usopp and the hero who failed his
way to the top buggy the clown but now
this next fact might make you rethink
completely who the actual strongest
straw hat is and that's because Nico
Robin had an even higher bouncy as a kid
than the strongest creature in the world
kaido when they were both the same age
and that means that for the absolute
most insane hidden fact in all of One
Piece we have the secret symbol of the
left eye now because throughout the
story Oda has drawn many characters with
their left eye closed including these
volume covers this symbol also shows up
on the map of Jaya and even on this
abstract painting in dressrosa and I bet
you can't even imagine just how much
this symbol reveals about where to find
love feel what the ancient kingdom was
and how the future of the story will go
and just to top it all off here's one
insane bonus fact because did you know
who the only character is who rejected
the chance to join both Roger and the
straw hat crew as a kid well that would
be Frankie and if you want to know why
exactly he initially rejected both of
these insane Crews well you can watch
that video right here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one